welcome back to the new rock stars
debrief we loved all the feedback we got
on the new name and a couple of you even
spotted the easter egg here's what it
was the first letters of the words in
the name new Rock sirs debrief are in Rd
nerd right yeah that was it if you
thought it was the lightning bolt in our
logo that's been there for about three
years
yeah thanks for catching up though the
lady boat was very insulted she's
between her pets to stand out and but
what are we learning about today uh well
today we're talking about this new black
widow movie news and this whole idea of
our ratings in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe how will that change the Marvel
world as we know it we also got some big
news about the Batman movie yeah always
in production never a hero a movie that
will come eventually and some news about
whether or not r2d2 has a girlfriend all
the bots want to know I mean r2d2 is a
bit of a flirt it meant I don't see that
one settling down I'm Erik Voss joining
me today is Philip Malina hi this is me
Philip Malina that's Philip and I'm Erik
okay great so you want to know what I've
heard yeah well this is in case you
haven't heard this is a podcast yeah
speaking of heard right you can hear
this now without having a look at us
it's because it's available as a podcast
now you guys have been demanding that
for a long time and we took it
personally because we thought it was
about our appearance
we caved and you can find our audio
version now on the Himalaya app or also
wear your Apple podcast wherever you get
your podcast there's like a million
services stitches a creeper all of them
Bob your homies listening to someone
else in their car but if you got it from
the Himalaya it actually literally
supports our own podcast so we really
appreciate if you got it there it's got
a kind of like youtube style thing
they're doing there it's a little bit
more like a podcast with a community
built into it you can subscribe leave
comments for us on there and then we
actually can review them and address
them in the next episode it feels like
home there again it literally supports
us which is why I feel really good at
but I knew it feels like home yeah homes
are supportive yeah but okay actually
Eric what have you heard in terms of
this our rating
stuff imma go okay well this is what is
going on the director of Marvel
standalone Black Widow movie Cate
Shortland she directed film festival
darlings like the Berlin Syndrome and
the writer is Jack Sheaffer and she
wrote and directed and produced the
movie timer now here's the deal about
this neither of these are like
big-budget crazy special-effects movies
but Black Widow doesn't actually really
have any magical or superhuman ability
she's like a spy she's deadly with
hand-to-hand combat but also what's
crazy about these movies are rated R and
we're hearing that the MC use Black
Widow movie might also be rated R that's
the word on the street according to
gossip blogs but people have been right
about things before so we kind of trust
these sources so what do we think this
means why do we think this movie this
Black Widow movie might benefit from an
R rating well first of all right now it
probably is just the first of a number
of our rated Marvel movies not to come
and we want to get into that too but
specifically Black Widow yeah imagine
Black Widow not as an r-rated movie
that's boring as hell it's it's a spy
movie and we've seen spy movies that can
be fun and not be r-rated but once it's
it's like a serious one where people die
and and and you know assassinations are
happening it's like if you cut away from
the assassination or something also I
mean not because it's Black Widow but
because it's part of the spy genre sex
is usually a big part of them you know
like again it's just like everything
would feel I think like neutered when
the spy genre is such an adult one I
mean obviously and Fleming set it up
that way to be kind of like a man's
fantasy of what he could be like but
that kind of stuck with it and now the
genre works yeah I think within our
rating this is a real opportunity to let
see what Black Widow can really do you
know as a member of an ensemble and as a
member of the Avengers she's just
someone on the ground level who like
gets in a good punch every now and then
and has like strong relationships with
the other characters we can't really see
the extent of her abilities and as a
former KGB operative she's deadly she's
really one of these people who wears the
black hat and the white hat and that's
something that the movies have addressed
with like black widow dealing with her
past and dealing with that guilt she's
had blood on her hands I got right on my
ledger
you know it's what
says but we'd never actually seen her be
able to do that so with an r-rating you
can really explore the levels of
violence and the levels of intensity and
adult themes if you look at a show like
the Americans on the Americans yeah they
really violent show like you can't
that's not like a PG 13 or 14 ages or
older show to why it's really like an
r-rating I would say hard are right with
with everything nudity and violence yeah
I mean they they should have a number of
headshots in that now I want to paint a
picture of like what movie we're talking
about here because I think it's very
easy for us to say like oh it should be
r-rated like people say that all the
time about every movie but I want you to
remember what it was like to watch The
Bourne Identity mm-hmm
and the Bourne pharmacy and a lot of
those first Bourne movies the idea of
assassins going after each other there's
a story with Black Widow where when the
USSR is breaking up the government
decides to eliminate its assassins and
they're gonna take her out and so it's
other assassins were hunting her one I
think that that's a good story for this
movie because it has her breaking away
from the villainous USSR it's usually
established it would be weird if like
she's like trying to take down America
for the whole movie but it's hard to
root for yeah exactly but if yeah she's
like but if she's being hunted by on her
own government then you're gonna have
that thing where the the reason I
reference Bourne is because Bourne is
being hunted by the other people that
are like him and those fights are like
insane like the blood that is pouring
how do these these two people by the end
is is pretty realistic to her like yeah
if you have to amazingly trying to
Assassin's trying to take each other out
they're gonna cause some damage so I
want you to compare that to maybe alias
where alias was I thought a very fun TV
show very great action in it but it
almost had this air of like there's this
protective bubble around Jennifer Garner
where like she would like take some hit
sort of and then like have a bruise on
her forehead I think like there was a
there was an implication that they
pulled out her teeth once but like she
like spit out like a little bit of red
or Dover but what you don't actually
like feel that she's ever actually in
danger and I think we want to see that
like we do in the Bourne movies where we
feel those face punches yeah and I think
it
all comes back to making black widow the
most active version of the character
that she can really be in letting her
spread her wings in a movie and her
backstory is very dark
Phillip was going into it there's also
some elements of her backstory where she
was forced to be sterilized so that she
didn't have a family which they case
alluded to before but yeah yes yes you
must have some real major demons and
some major trauma from that that they
could really explore in this kind of
movie yeah I also think that like we
were kind of teasing before a little bit
like this is really just an entry point
for Marvel into the r-rated genre so
that's something I really want to
discuss your first IQ and pick your
brain about two is what does it mean if
we've essentially like broken the seal
on r-rated movies specifically in the
MCU obviously we've had r-rated Marvel
properties with Deadpool and with Logan
but to me Logan's just a perfect example
right when we saw that r-rated Logan we
were like right Wolverine not you know
the candy version of Wolverine is that
phrase people say the candy I don't want
to use that word because this is rated G
but yeah it when Logan came out we were
like yeah Wolverine is his powers are
dude like aside from generating healing
art like destroy someone's flesh right
if they ever show that it's got I
remember they couldn't before they
couldn't show the blood of an exit wound
of Wolverine Wolverine would like to
slice through you and and come out and
you were like inside you were all water
yeah it was like that uh or that movie
was at house of about a house of a glass
so one word they look whate go ship does
the same thing yeah they slice through
you and there's like a second where
you're still alive and then your body
slides off like sliced meat yeah yeah
yeah it's just one of those yeah final
destination wires found its way into
another cinematic you know I think yeah
I hear what you're saying with Logan was
such a great script to read because you
know Joe or mangled James mangled ruin
this whole thing at the beginning like
the fights are gonna be like real fights
and if you've ever like gone do a boxing
match or like been in a
where there's a fight happening like to
hear the sound of a punch hitting flesh
is like disgusting like you can it's
like wet you get out here like like
muscle getting bruised like it's not a
good sound of here like this land on
flesh it's it's disgusting so it's it
was great and Logan to see that kind of
hole sound design and all that violence
great example you guys should look up
you can find that script pretty easily
Logan script and that opening that
Eric's talking about it not only talks
about how the the violence is gonna be
real I think I remember there being a
part there that said like this isn't
gonna be a superhero movie with like
these huge CGI sequences yeah yeah and I
think that if you applied that paragraph
directly to Black Widow specifically it
makes perfect sense but it's like what
she's gonna be caught in like a Doctor
Strange dementia like that's not that
wouldn't fit her so they do have to find
it somewhere else and yeah just like
Logan found it it's kind of in the
directed violence the reason I'm excited
about this idea you're mentioning the
way r-rated movies could affect all the
Marvel world they Disney's brand is
family-friendly of course but they have
touchstone pictures they have these
adult sub brands underneath the studio
yeah any nights yeah or yeah or Marvel
max was an idea that they might my Danny
dark was yeah yeah yeah that's the one
we want to see but they have a total
license to release it could still be
like a Marvel property but it's released
through touch-tone pictures so people
don't see that Disney Cinderella's
castle with oh my god murdering each
other so they have a way that they can
do this from a business sense also
Disney's acquiring Fox there's no reason
why they have to break up the Fox studio
it can just still be the Fox brand and
they can release movies under the Fox
name it's just they get all the money
and then it's valuable brand Fox's it'd
be crazy for them to break it up but
what's great is this models what comics
have already done comics started
something that was kid friendly family
friendly and then as comic readers start
to get older and they wanted more
sophisticated stories you started to
have some darker stories like Watchmen
come out in the 80s and Batman started
murdering people in certain comics like
you had what if comics where things got
really dark you had like venom and
carnage
things got incredibly violent
cannibalism and and yeah in fact another
storyline that's just popping up in my
head
so the the x-men universe being absorbed
you know which by the way I think in one
year we're gonna be having this
conversation about the new casting of
Wolverine or ever like it is right
around the corner it has a lot of
violence in it it has you know sexual
violence it has cannibalism at the House
of M storyline would be great for if you
wanted to bring in a Scarlet Witch but
like a lot of people die you know like
it'd be interesting to do it in a way
that wasn't as tidy as everyone can turn
into dust right and all we want to see
is like more diversity and different
kinds of stories and this is the way you
can do it doesn't mean the end of
family-friendly Avengers team-up movies
or the end of like spider-man movies in
the way that comics right now have a ton
of different kind of stories if you're a
kid there's stuff for you if you're an
adult who wants like more like
literature type stories with more adult
themes there's a place for that as well
I like with things like infinity war
like that was the first big movie comic
crossover event that felt like what
Marvel Comics were trying to do all your
characters in a movie together and the
fact that it worked I think is a good
sign that what people like about comics
can also be what people like about these
kind of movies too and that includes
like having some serious adult comic
book adaptations I mean Watchmen did
come out but I think it was a bit out of
its time had some weird adaptation
issues but now maybe like the Watchmen
series on HBO has like a chance because
people are more willing to digest these
kind of stories with superheroes
yeah or if they're not now it exists on
a gradient where like fine you have your
your kind of movie you know new mutants
maybe wouldn't get to be like a hard-r I
don't think it is but a horror movie
like everyone has their there's a home
for every genre inside of Marvel instead
of oh I know a lot of people when DC EU
came out and it was like we're going
hard dark fast and it was the concept of
they're only gonna be that that I think
turned everybody off but Marvel is kind
of like Disney right Disney has a home
for everything I think Marvel does -
yeah and Disney's going to need to build
up all these brands because it's
impossible to just be one like size fits
all with your stories like people say oh
this needs a family-friendly brand so
they have to do certain things it's like
no they're a major corporation right
wants to hit all four quadrants of
people who watch movies and they
certainly don't want to make the same
kind of movie
and there's ton there's tons of overlap
I mean ourselves included bro so I
remember the first mp3 my brother ever
downloaded showed me was Donald Duck
getting a bj and he was like look at you
can download these kinds of things now
people can be interested in both as my
point yeah whatever your interests are
you don't have to worry about tumblr not
hosting it more Disney will host it for
you but this is exciting let us know
what you think about r-rated Marvel
movies do you want to see them all in a
separate different studio so if you know
if it's a touch tone or Fox you know it
can be r-rated or are you okay with all
the movies just coming out as they are
yeah and I'm really interested to know
what you guys think leaving them
comments are either on youtube or on
Himalaya of what stories can be done now
yeah break the seal on r-rated movies in
the MTU yep we're gonna move on to our
weekly trivia question as always we're
gonna ask this question we want a same
question every week eventually we have
the 51st state syndrome where you know
we just gotta get reset momento that's
another example of the movie whoever
gets a closer answer will get to do our
goodbyes and the loser is gonna have to
do some silly gesture that hopefully
someone online will turn into an
animated gif what's happened maybe twice
maybe twice most of the time it's like
people who work here who have to turn
but hey it'll catch on so our question
is what is the highest grossing r-rated
movie of all time that is an interesting
question I have some ideas so I saw a
chart where apparently like most movies
that have been made in any given year
are r-rated I always felt like pg-13 was
like the bulk of the movies that are
made most movies are like these art
house movies that have like nudity or
some kind of violence and over the years
that has declined or it's gone up and
down they show the chart of like what
the share is of movies I think we're
both writing down our answers by the way
if you wanna write yours down on your
arm at home I think that the
the reason for that is that it's
actually harder to keep things like I
don't know it to censor yourself in this
very particular way that the NPA defines
for ratings where it's like like
counting your f-bombs like that's just
the kind of like your average rider for
I'm thinking indie films probably uh
speaking of indie it was an indie film
right it was Temple of Doom that it was
the first time where they created there
was a beach right yeah like Sundance I'm
like why is Sundance all Indiana Jones
movies there's yeah Temple of Doom has
like some very violent graphic scenes
and after that I think the MPAA is like
we need to create a category of what a
difference between PG and pg-13 is
because that was like rated PG jaws was
rated PG a lot of these like older
violent movies where a lot of like a sea
full frontal shark nudity yeah Donna is
like a censor yes sound so I guess it's
if you think a lot of people were making
movies directors writers they're they're
adults who like want to tell their kind
of stories and you got it it's harder to
make a story that kids will enjoy that's
safe for them not interested well
Phillip what have you heard from this
week what's the news what okay so you
know that I'm constantly digging up
Batman news because this is my favorite
thing to listen about or to read about
so I got to actually kind of interesting
things here first up exciting update is
just the like it feels like we just get
a lot of Joker news we get non-stop joke
and you know your movies yeah but we
haven't gotten that much actual official
details about the Batman movie at the
Matt Reeves one who met Reeves like
coming off of just like hit after hit
movie and I've been so excited and he's
the one that we're not hearing anything
about well now we're finally hearing
first off it's definitely happening it's
going to be released in 2021 okay all
right so we'll each be 21 years that's
great and and just very exciting will
share a cocktail and the movie itself
the movie itself has been described as I
feel like I've been pitching this for
years something that focuses on his
detective skills world a great detective
yeah he's the world's greatest detective
that means like better than Sherlock
right and there's just more
Sherlock franchises and yet we've never
really gone down the detective Pat other
than you see him sitting at a computer
and he's like just hacking yeah he's a
supercomputer who does all the sleep and
those supercomputers detective yeah or
sometimes Alfred drops in the clue it's
like you sure to figure that out Batman
yeah so I love a movie set in a mystery
which some of the best Batman comics
stories are mysteries and so you know
they'll probably oh I wonder if they'll
adapt there's a couple of interesting
options of things we haven't seen yet
and senemo with him but we hadn't heard
much about it so I was worried it wasn't
gonna happen but or something was gonna
go wrong but it is gonna happen but we
also learned that Ben Affleck yes
officially not gonna be in it even
tweeted like you know his best wishes
about it he was that's such a far
distance look how far we've come on
banana yeah remember he was going to not
only direct it not only star in it he
was also writing the script he wrote a
draft yeah did write a draft right I
remember I think he was saying like it
was harder than he thought
butchie's Academy Award for writing I
can't wrap my head around this guy he's
not from Boston but now he's not even
involved at all yeah yep so Matt Reeves
himself is gonna write and direct it and
then also reportedly they're looking for
a younger version of Batman which i
think is fine it was a little weird but
they started at they're like 45 plus
year old Batman with the Ben Affleck
version but we're like you know Dick
Grayson was dead just like let's just
jump way ahead
no one wants Batman movies yeah but I
also heard this rumor this and you guys
probably been hearing this too that
they're looking at unexpected casting
for the role of Bruce Wayne / Batman so
like for instance in my head I'm into
the idea of like a who played Bruce
Banner originally uh originally Ravana
Eric Bana yeah I like not Lou Ferrigno
yeah I could see Lou Ferrigno No Eric
Bana it has a great look of like oh he
looks really rich but has really sad
eyes oh yeah and that to me has always
been a Bruce Wayne and her energy turns
out a lot of rumors are like nah don't
even like think of your normal people
like I heard Michael B Jordan
no it wasn't he brought up her Superman
at some point Jordan was brought up for
Wonder Woman everything yeah yeah yeah
he is kind of flying everything but Eric
before we get to our other Batman is
that I'm also excited about who do you
think should play Batman next who would
be I'll challenge you also though since
they're Saints gonna be unexpected the
weirdest Batman well we have like a lot
of like with things like stranger things
and it and in Shazam as well like we
have a lot of like young actors like we
have the this era of people who are like
mid teenage years and they're really
really good like when we were growing up
every kid movie if you go back very
recently it's yeah right we're yeah post
Millennials there's it's it's sometimes
you watch kids and it's always hard for
me to watch child actors cuz they just
don't have the skill set yet it's rare
and if they are really good at it then
they're a bit creepy sometimes mom dad
are you dead but these kids now are
freaking great yeah like the Game of
Thrones actors have been really good I
mean no Bobby Brown as me yeah I mean
any of those kids in stranger things
within wolf art get mad at Matarazzo is
adorable yeah the kid in inches am
either of those raise it right or strong
and yeah they're yeah he's in it he's in
it he's in it yeah I so there are some
younger actors they might be a little
too young like some people brought up
needed to play grizzled Batman the
grizzled Batman or any detective at all
yeah the PD around Batman who is the the
guy who didn't get cast as solo that we
thought would be good as solo who's in
The Fault in Our Stars on Sol Elgort
Ansel Elgort he could be pretty I like
that guy I think he's pretty good you're
going you're going year one yes but
that's some kind of weird
option I don't know there's let's see
about Michael Cera or Michael Cera
hasn't been in anything in 10 years
because we've been bulking up for pepper
gonna recognize them what is a bulky
Michael Cera look like
Michael Rapaport and I oh yeah we got
rebel Wilson we got Lindsay Lohan yeah
wildcard choices yeah or they could go
really super old wasn't that blast time
we had this discussion with like wow
he's exactly who Clint Eastwood is who I
always imagined actually was playing oh
this actually segues very nicely into my
other Batman story I always imagined
that if they did a Batman Beyond movie
that Clint Eastwood would play the older
Batman and now he's a hundred and
sixty-five years old and he could still
do it I think but sidenote DC is
apparently developing an animated Batman
Beyond movie they've done one before but
it was a very very long time ago back
when Batman Beyond was return of the
Joker yeah exactly but also it had some
like there was also another one too and
like they what's so great about the
Batman Beyond stories is that they it's
almost like a where are they now they
love to like play with like what happens
to Barbara Gordon you know what happens
to I you know the family unit of the
Batman family
yeah whatever the Robins exactly it's
always just so so interesting to see
yeah and also it has a little bit of
that that feeling of you know Eric and I
were both very obsessed with The
Simpsons and there's that play out there
that is based on if only one episode of
the Cape Fear up escape year episode of
The Simpsons if that was the only thing
that was left behind of modern media and
pop-culture how it would affect the
future that was what like a city that is
completely founded on just the ideas of
right yeah
so Batman Beyond is far enough in the
future where it like looks at like okay
what if like the Joker was this like
figure that actually did all these
things he almost would become like a
religion and disciples like that would
follow and stuff so it just has these
like really interesting impacts so I'm
really excited to see another movie from
it obviously this is in direct response
to into the spider-verse because they
are talking about potentially doing this
as a wider release not just yeah the
ones that I download every week on my
yeah when we come out like three or four
times
but yeah Majan if they hit it with that
level of like intensity of like we're
gonna release a really good Batman
Beyond I love Batman Beyond it's not as
good as Batman the Animated Series like
the closest thing
yeah and it's it has the same kind of
aesthetic it has its own like gothic
aesthetic and it feels very specific at
the art design of the show is really
great and the the world building on that
show was fantastic and it did feel like
in a really good way like a derivative
but set in the same world and that the
Simpsons thing is and I would love to
I'm super excited about this especially
yeah with a with a wide release like I
hope that they do more of that not just
you know the ones that are proven to be
successful but yeah I think it also can
put some really good talent behind and
great I think it has a benefit of so
Nightwing is a character that is very
interesting very charming you know
former Robin goes off and does his own
thing but one of the biggest obstacles
that that that character has is that he
exists simultaneously with Batman in
just a different town and it's like yeah
you're Batman's sidekick you went off
and started your own thing
you're the JC Shaw's a of this situation
where there's always going to be just in
Batman Timberlake like you can't you
can't outshine that guy but with Terry
the the character taking over the mantle
of Batman way in the future like then he
get to have a new character who is kind
of similar to the Grayson but has a
disconnect of like it's not like other
Bruce wayne/batman is gonna show up and
save the day right now I would love to
be the JC Shaw's a of any situation
you're the JC shows they have no
rockstars hey I'll take the best dancer
but there was it was that what jay-z was
he was the dancer of the group I always
thought he had the job you think
Beyonce's married to jay-z shaza
what it was what have you heard
the DC Universe you were telling me
earlier yeah there's uh this is like a
great week for like DC News knowing that
the Batman is coming but also we now
have official word that James Gunn is
writing and directing Suicide Squad 2
which we've been up to because because I
feel like he's had a whole other
franchise he did have all the franchise
about like misfit criminals banding
together to join their universe and a
supposedly family friendly company
that's about to do our rated movies but
whatever okay so yeah we suspected since
he was gonna be writing this that he's
going to also be directing it cuz that's
how he works like with the guardians of
the galaxy oh that was it those movies
he wrote and directed them he picked the
soundtracks for them he's like an otter
it's like his project his it was called
a james gunn film which to get that
joint
yeah it means you have to have control
over a lot of aspects not just in the
writing directing but over the whole
project but we're hearing that the movie
and this is interesting will be more of
a reboot than a sequel so they're going
to feature mostly all new cast and
characters and actors so it's not going
to be like new actors playing Deadshot
and Captain Boomerang and Killer Croc
they're gonna feature new characters
from the DC world and he's just gonna
start with a blank slate yeah I love
that the best way to go I'm not gonna
fight you at all yeah there are some
elements of Suicide Squad the first
movie that I liked the Harley Quinn was
great I think Captain Boomerang had some
good lines there were some good jokes in
there but there's just a lot it was a
big mess and I and I kind of want James
Gunn I can imagine him taking elements
from it said mostly all new cast
yeah yes sure they'll bring some
characters back but one of the best
reasons I honestly I mean III don't mind
the character and I don't mind the actor
but Will Smith as Deadshot in that movie
from what I gather it was one of the
reasons why the movie felt like it was
Frankenstein together from a bunch of
different things
it's when you have stars of that of that
magnitude I mean it's like casting Tom
Cruise right right I he now has to be a
huge part of the production in the
creative and I mean that's not gonna
work with James dawn yeah he like
everyone in the Guardians cast truly
totally trusted James Gunn's vision
right
project and if you compare like what he
did with the characters compared to the
comics there's like a 2014 or it was
like 2011 is when the guardians comics
like Bri released the original like 70s
guardians comics were all over the place
and they weren't particularly popular so
he was able to take things that he could
really like redefine it didn't really
have to stay sacred to certain things so
I think he's a guy who's always better
off taking things from the ground up and
starting with his own vision of things
and kind of almost pretending like the
first movie didn't happen yeah I mean
that's kind of you know I compare him to
Phil Lord and Chris Miller because they
also have this thing where it's like
we're gonna reinvent your universe for
you but we're gonna do it our own way
and we saw how like when they tried to
do it something that they had There was
competing opinions with solo okay guys
start down right so same thing with him
where I think it's kind of like DC is
obviously kind of like have at it right
do do what you want and I think that's
perfect for him I actually think this
movie's gonna be good yeah I'm excited
for this and do you think which
characters do you think will be coming
back and which new characters do you
think we could see I mean the problem I
wouldn't be surprised if if they're one
thing the studio is pushing is for a
Harlequin to being the center of the
piece she's a real breakout from the
first one yeah I think that we're gonna
struggle to see the Joker come back
because they'll have been other Joker
films it's just weirder he's honestly
more the weirdest of that yeah I don't
think you need the Joker in a Suicide
Squad movie I think that was a misstep
with the first one yeah we'll get Amanda
Waller again yeah yeah if she's the one
thing that needs to stay it's a rotating
group of criminals but Amanda Waller is
always when put together usually dead
shots there right yeah but I mean I'm
hoping that they let them let them off
yeah retire yeah well let's know what
you think about this in the comments
below but who should be in the new
Suicide Squad yeah yeah who should the
new suits quite line up be and Philip
puts some other news that you heard this
week there's just catching us up I guess
the screenwriter of Doctor Strange is it
see see Robert cargo there yeah he's
coming back which is fantastic yeah I
think that he actually it like nailed
that weird tone of the doctor strange
energy Ian's got there
a real good partnership yeah so he's
coming back to do the sequel Doctor
Strange even stranger yeah doctor
stranger yeah Jon Favreau also posted a
behind-the-scenes picture from the
mandalorian and this is what we're
alluding to earlier it kind of looks
like r2d2 might have a girlfriend
because this droid has little accents of
pink yeah another astromech squeeze it
feels out of their way to make it seem
like you know in Sunbury 2019 but this
is a whole different this long long ago
so maybe pink means like feminine rubber
I don't know that it means that now but
it feels like they're purposely saying
this is a girl droid this is a girl I
think pb8 is also a girl but most people
don't know that
oh is that yes oh that's canon but over
here I didn't remind me of that the
actual r2d2 look similar droid that was
pink that wasn't forced away right yeah
but that was more of a for a fan it was
a yeah I can make a wish I terminally
ill yeah and who yeah it was like a
special sister or just a platonic friend
yes also fine or gender-neutral boy one
who does it leather colors defined yeah
or maybe his boss right women make great
leaders too yep
listen to these two cooks alright what
else we got I was speaking of powerful
women birds of prey gave us some more
pictures and well they're just like
sneaky set photos or whatever but you
can actually see if you were looking at
this picture it's a moment where Harley
Quinn looks addressed like when Elvis
had his like cowboy style she's got that
look and she's inside of a place of
exotic animals which I mean they're like
Starbucks these stores are on every
street Murray's exotic Mary but what is
exciting about that is that it could
mean that we are going to meet her
hyenas a little paya a pair of hyenas a
bud and Lou which in my head I'm
imagining are just gonna be Whoopi
Goldberg exactly what I'm scared they're
gonna do is it's gonna have like I don't
know like a bebop and rocksteady energy
but I think if they just make them like
some vicious I you know sand just leave
it at that that'll be a fun reference
CGI the hyenas or do we use puppeteers
or live it oh no CGI hyenas can't put
our working actor hyenas like I mean
would that lead to cruelty toward hyenas
cuz they're so annoying they're just
they're gonna bad things are gonna
happen to those I just don't like people
laughing at you yeah I prefer it I did
for it so give a comedy show tonight but
who is this monster behind her in the
back if you're listening to the podcast
there's like a figure with like two
glowing golden eye makeup person and why
do they have terrifying eyes like when
you shine a light into the woods and you
see raccoons looking back to you that's
what we're seeing here that means you
have a soul oh good yeah whatever you
think was worried I was worried well now
comes the time to move on to our new
rock stars news lightning round
- you know how this works you guys tweet
us questions I'm going to fire them at
Philip and I myself and we have to
answer yeah as quickly without
hesitation as possible are we ready my
heartbeat is raising alright here we go
for me at black staying 1302 wants to
know will James Rhodes be at the
airplane base in Captain Marvel as Carol
Danvers love interests like in the
comics and does the timeline work out
James Brodie would be pretty young
unless you talk about in the modern
times no I think I think it does work I
mean if we go with the Don Cheadle
version he's like a 50 right now yeah
but yeah I got but in the 90s and if she
was in - yeah in the 80s yeah I don't I
don't know if it would've been old
enough unless you talk about they start
dating and she doesn't really age now
that lightning I'm gonna say no I don't
think so Philip at nut slot
meerkat
that's life well how would you get
someone who knows nothing about Batman
hooked ooh who knows nothing about
Batman this is a person who doesn't know
language or how to feed themselves this
is a person you found in the woods like
I guess taking a feral person and the
only thing you wanna tell him about is
Batman yeah and then just give him a
Batman year one or or honestly like even
Dark Knight Returns like even though it
starts like it like so much later in the
career but honestly like just one of the
good solid graphic novels will do it or
no wait they're learning English have
them learn English I learned English
from Sesame Street have them learn
English from the animated station there
you go yes I need at Aaron Lee with a
bunch of numbers wants to know if Doctor
Strange keeps a list of all beings in
the universe that may be a threat to
earth why do you think he didn't know
about Santos when Hulk crash-landed in
infinity war I don't know if his list is
complete I know he's keeping like we're
talking about thor ragnarok selections
complete yeah he didn't he had a list of
things and that's why you didn't want
Loki on on the planet I mean it doesn't
mean that he knows all right he's
omniscient but also yeah Venice's is
hugely famous and I'll say that like a
strange seemed to have a bit of
knowledge on who they know sand the
Infinity stones and what the Infinity
stones were who they were when banner
got there because he was helping his
kind of tag teaming with banner to Stark
that whole we briefed on what he had
right so like how else would he know
about the Infinity stones if he hasn't
done some research yeah I guess he just
didn't go like you're on my list
Yeah right Philip at Martin Pitt wants
to know which obscure Batman villain
would you like to see in any of the new
upcoming DC related movies new obscure
well we talked to the hush for that's
not very obscure
zaz that's coming to birds of prey oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah he would be that
would be my guess
yeah I don't know a face hasn't really
shown up for so many things but it's
it's feels like maybe they just can't
get the lightning lightning yep yeah for
me at ob1 bologna wants to know what his
Batman's favorite show to binge watch on
Netflix I don't work for Netflix what's
Batman's favorite trip maybe Punisher he
might be the one thing he kind of
relates his tortured soul who's a
vigilante incorrect it's Marie Kondo
cleaning up the streets a Batcave is so
organized
she sparks joy for him Phillip Erin Lee
coming back wants to know if dr. strange
keeps a low it's the same question same
question to you
thank you for firing all these questions
at us and continue to keep those
questions coming we always love hearing
from you guys
yeah and start dropping them also in the
Himalaya yappin we'll try to get to them
on there too yes and now comes the time
for a 15-second shout out Phillip and I
each have 15 seconds to shout out plug
or ramble about anything we want
Phillip do you got something well I mean
I'm mostly just and give it to you for
you for your time
but I just check out my favorite murder
fun podcast interesting yeah yeah I
think by the time you're listening to
this my my show will have already gone
I'm doing a live monthly show of your
first Friday the month Phillip will be
the one we're about to do right after
this but follow me on Twitter and you'll
you'll see for the next date the one
thing I want you to watch I just tweeted
this like the day before yesterday
it's a BBC science video about
anthropologists who are studying like
the voice the vocal cords of
Neanderthals and it's just this weird
clip of a woman's like oh it was
squatter well I have Elliot here and she
brings in an actor and just to reproduce
the sound of what in the end result
would sound like an antipope Elliot cap
- 3 D goes 1 2 3 now make it higher
because they have they had a higher
voice Neanderthals
there and he goes one two three and
already I'm like I'm in hello with it
just keeps kinky keeps in there no one
breaks and by the end of it he's going
like in her face and no one's laughing
except me I'm dying laughing and then
they do some crazy horror imagery at the
end to transform him into a Neanderthal
it's uh it's amazing why this was
presented as a fact thing when it's
clearly a comedic one favorite things
I've seen them for that Eric what's our
answer to our trivia question to that
okay so here's a gif of shame steak so
again if you're listening on the podcast
the stakes of this are that we have to
act out something silly and you can
follow us on social media at MIT rock
stars to find it at some point and
you'll see whether or not who won I
guess and the question was what is the
highest grossing r-rated movie of all
time and we both said the same thing
passion to Christ which is a correct
answer
it also says Deadpool would also be
accepted necessary it's a
highest-grossing and national film
passion Christ
domestic film well what does that say
about our culture that Passion of the
Christ and Deadpool it's like one-half a
culture likes to [ __ ] people to movies
and buses to show their support for
things and the other half will watch
people keep trying to face over and over
again
but also degree guess which movie were
talking about cuz it's not as obvious ed
yeah
Deadpool fans get shipped in buses yeah
so what would you like to do sure what
should we both be punished as a result
of this alright I do a gift for shame
together
yeah you do a different one no don't
make any sense to anyone okay so what
Philip and I have to do
someone mispronounced Aria or Aria and
if you want to correct them so bad it
hurts okay so that's how we should read
the goodbye
no our producer who is sitting across
from us is telling us that it's
incorrect the way we would do it is we
will stand up and we will just try to
correct someone while feeling
the pain of not doing it we want to but
we can't
alright and we'll do that for a second
and then we'll give air our goodbyes
this is really great content for you on
the podcast also check us out on YouTube
to just listen to the mm-hmm it's not
sure it's fine that you'd like Americans
Americans
I'm Ameria what a time to be alive
hey now use that gif in any situation
I'm sure it'll make sense makes our
facial expressions spoke volumes thank
you for watching for this week's episode
of new rockstars debrief or listening if
you're listening to us over the podcast
and I want to thank Phil Molina and
myself we can find Phil Oh Phil up on
Twitter at FEMA find me at a vas and of
course subscribe to us at new rock stars
on Twitter follow us at Twitter and
subscribe to this channel on YouTube and
subscribe to this podcast where every
listened podcast but preferably himalaya
because they they helped us in so many
ways and yeah thank you for listening
leave comments on the podcasts leave
comments on their channel talk to us we
love hearing from you give me one more
thing to do have a great weekend
everyone and see you next week bye